coid cases are rising in the US and
across the Atlantic as well European
countries have reported than 400 more
than
41,000 new cases in just the past seven
days in some areas new case loads are at
all time highs Holly Williams reports
now on new rules in Britain and other
nations in response to the latest
outbreak they declared a state of
emergency in the Spanish Capital Madrid
last week Banning non-essential travel
in and out of the
city with 7,000 police officers to
enforce the new
restrictions Italy and Poland have made
it compulsory to wear a mask in public
places and France has put Paris and
several other cities on maximum alert
forcing bars and gyms to shut meanwhile
India has become the second country
after the US to record more than 7
million infections its official death
toll is over 100,000 the real figure
could be much higher some experts are
warning of pandemic fatigue but
Professor Robert West who advises the
British government says it's really
confusion you're saying that they want
to obey the rules but but they don't
know what the rules are there is
confusion about what the rules are H and
they definitely want to obey them there
is a myth going around that people are
showing less adherence to the rules as
they get this uh concept of fatigue
actually the evidence in the UK doesn't
support that starting on Saturday
authorities in Germany's capital Berlin
implemented a nighttime curfew for the
first time since the early years of the
Cold War seven decades
ago it's such bad luck said this young
man whose birthday party was brought to
an early
end here in the United Kingdom the prime
minister is expected to announce a new
three tiered alert system later on today
but business groups are angry that it
could mean more closures and even more
lost income Gail Oh Boy sign of the
times it seems thank you very much Holly
Williams reporting from London